hey what's up my name's samuel lee's i
just completed on another piece of land
i'm a property developer the plan here
is to build
an apartment block so there's gonna be
five apartments
two bedrooms ensuites it's gonna be
amazing i'm gonna document everything
and i'm really excited and tony good to
see you hey
this is tony tony's my business coach
great business man
you've generated over a hundred million
in business and now wanting to invest in
me why you want to invest in this
project
uh i've never done a land development
deal in my life but yeah super excited
to be
part of it i want to learn uh from the
master
thank you man yeah it's gonna cost us
about
210 000 pounds to buy it yes nick what's
happening
see every everybody uh everybody's
beeping and congratulating us you know
what's that hey oh yeah we bought it
cheers bro yeah man i did your
carson um dfe oh you did the dfa yeah oh
man that's awesome right everyone's
driving past stopping me saying
samuel did you just buy that land i'm
one of your students all my students
around here for some reason missed it
they missed it how could you miss it i
don't know how you can miss it i don't
know have we met before
oh wonderful i can't believe i saw you
standing outside this yeah and i live
down the road
and you were saying i bet you no one
recognizes it i'm sitting there thinking
why didn't i see that why didn't i see
it i did so i did a video here
uh i released it about two weeks ago and
i was like hey what's up i've just
but that that that filming took place
six weeks ago
i sat on the footage until the day i
completed and then i put it out
and i'm so glad i did because within
five minutes everyone was putting the
postcode
in the comments i was like i'm glad i
waited
you know incredible i live just around
the corner here and it's absolutely
fantastic
to come here and see what samuel's
managed to do and give us an example
of what's possible to boost the economy
in this area loads of northerners are
complaining that samuel is coming up
north
he's taking all the houses i live 10
minutes away from this spot right now
many northerners are complaining that
samuel is coming and he's taking all the
houses
samuel is not taking the houses he's
building the houses around here
in the economy i went to crash course oh
[ __ ]
where was it cool
yeah we just bought it yeah
[Laughter]
it's amazing how many people around
leeds have done my training literally
new what's up people are driving past
everyone's just
doing the window down and going save
your leads
crazy so apartment one apartment two
yep three four five nice big one at the
top yeah so we're gonna
have lost loft apartment question is do
you reckon we'll get planned and
accepted for that
yeah hopefully we'll get planning but uh
he's gonna go in the next few weeks and
we'll so that's what we'll see if we get
our planning except it's gonna push the
value of the land right up the profit is
in the planning and to get planning you
need good planning consultants like
david yeah thank you
yeah and you need to find the sites but
samuel sound yeah
it makes a difference david's drawing up
the plans david you say this is the
first draft it looks kind of good
yeah i'm wondering why there needs to be
a second draft what's the plan
just to find tweaks from the bedrooms
some of the ensuites i mean again it was
just
first draft so you could see the layouts
yeah i like it
if you like the layouts we'll the
developers apartment one apartment two
three four five yeah ensuites in the
rooms
i hope we get if we don't get planning
for this what do we what do we do
well you thought with this particular
site in film
you can it's an infill site so yeah yeah
what is in film what does in film mean
infill means where there's a plot of
land in between other residential units
and there's you guys right so it's
fitting you're right you're in the area
you keep it but if they say no to flats
we could maybe build a couple houses
yes definitely they can't refuse the
houses because again
that's in keeping with the area so we'd
get two houses on that land yeah
yeah easy yeah which would still make
profit yeah because
the houses would be worth about 300 350.
easily it cost a lot less than that to
build it so
either way we're going to make money
really important to have a good power
team
right now we're we're in a building
construction warehouse
we've great building team david's a
planning consultant
great joint venture partner mantone
you've got to be around good people
and that's the most important thing i
could say david's part of the academy
yeah tony's part of the academy
everyone's part of the academy it looks
so me and him we're gonna we only met
yesterday yeah we're now gonna go into
business together we're gonna work
around the leeds area together oh wow
yep really amazing it's a great guy to
learn from good
instantly the people the energy just
pulling me oh that's so good
so that's good what do you think of my
apartments unbelievable i'm gonna buy
one you're gonna buy one
you want to live in one of them yeah
i'll hold you to it i'll give you a
discount what would you say
it's going to be done by give me 12
months 12 months yeah give me 12 months
june next year
yeah oh goodness most property
developers that are doing projects
they won't let people walking past
they'll be like oh come on in
coming into the meeting talk to my
planning consultant like not only am i
making a lot of money in development but
the thing is i'm opening up and i'm
letting other people get involved so
that they can do the same thing too and
that's the best thing
so if you want to get involved subscribe
to the channel you can do that below but
also if you see me in the street you see
me building houses you see me out doing
stuff
come and say hello i'll get you involved
you want to come and spend a day with me
the property investors crash course it's
free on the house
get booked on i'll see you there where
you going everything i know about
property
condensed into 12 hours and it's free
get booked on i'll see you there thanks
so much
see you next time